[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing albus dumbledore and
transfiguration more specifically we're
going to be honing in on one particular
branch of transfiguration the branch
surrounding becoming an animagus an
animagus simply put is a witch or wizard
that is able to transform themselves
into an animal and back again animagus
is a combination of the word animal and
the greek word magus which together form
animal wizard and omegas should not be
confused with metamorph magus which
refers to witches or wizards who are
born with the ability to change their
form at will there are quite a few known
anime guy exhibited throughout the
series including james potter a stag
sirius black a dog peter pettigrew a rat
rita skeeter a beetle and minerva
mcgonagall a cat just to name a few now
you might be thinking that's not a lot
of people surely there are more witches
and wizards that are anime guy right
but here's the thing it's not that
simple becoming an animagus is actually
an extremely rare and difficult ability
to master in fact so few people have
actually achieved this magical feat that
the ministry of magic requires all anime
guy to register their animagus status
the ministry of magic keeps tabs on
witches and wizards who can become
animals there's a register showing what
animal they become and their markings
and things and i went and looked
professor mcgonicle up on the register
and have only been seven anime guy this
century and petukru's name wasn't on the
list okay so all anime guy have to
register that is unless they want to
circumvent the ministry and hide their
ability an offense punishable by
imprisonment in azkaban with so few
registered animagus it really makes me
wonder what other characters are
secretly hiding this ability
well one of the first people that comes
to my mind is the powerful albus
dumbledore let's look at the facts here
yes becoming an animagus is difficult
but this is dumbledore we're talking
about here he definitely had the skill
and there's just no reason why he
wouldn't pursue this magical ability
and if we look at history dumbledore has
all sorts of ties to transfiguration
including serving as a columnist for
transfiguration weekly and at one stage
acting as head of the transfiguration
department at hogwarts jk rowling even
once revealed on pottermore the
dumbledore had helped minerva mcgonagall
become an animagus when she was his
student he helped mcgonagall a
transfiguration expert are you really
telling me this man didn't become one to
add to this hermione's research on the
subject only showed anime guy that
registered in the 20th century
and provided that dumbledore was alive
before then born in 1881 during the 19th
century it's very reasonable to deduce
that he'd become one but never
registered or just registered much
earlier on he didn't have to register
when he learned the ability and why
would he willingly register later i'm
sure that being able to transform into
an animal undetected certainly has its
perks and the complicated dumbledore
would have surely capitalized on this so
yes i think the dumbledore was an
animagus now the question is what was
his animagus form well this question can
be fairly reasonably answered the first
thing i want to mention is that your
animagus form is not something that you
can choose if you were destined to be a
rat
pettigrew then tough luck next it should
be stated there is a distinct
relationship between your animagus form
and your patronus form the animal into
which one turns if an animagus seems
always to be that which becomes the
patronus and what is dumbledore's
patronus why a phoenix of course and
that's it for this video what do you
guys think was dumbledore a secret
animagus or is this a bogus unjustified
theory comment down below
until next time remember happiness can
be found even in the darkest of times if
one only remembers to turn on the light
[Music]
you